oops your work
just everything where you want to max
out because we know you people are
listening to the rams jokers you
want to be the best in
every area of your life you want to make
a difference and we're here to give you
hope that you can and give you a clear
path
to be able to do it i'm ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show on the ramsay network
and your host today along with my
co-host
dr john deloney who's host of the dr
john deloney show
on the ramsey network and we're here
together triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five is the phone number as
we were because i was coming on the air
i had a bit of a chuckle because
my colleague who is well he's he's
unpredictable
uh is is a great way of saying it and we
have a lovely studio audience here
uh today and as i was just doing the
general opener
out of the corner of my eye john is at a
rock concert giving the rock on to our
to our fantastic studio audience out
there so i want to say
uh hello to them we'd love for you to
come watch the show sometime
from our ramsay solutions headquarters
uh you can figure out how to do that at
ramseysolutions.com and come visit us
we'd love to have you we've got free
drinks free food
and uh so john were you inspired to do
that by the dude wearing the beatles
shirt or is that just your normal
greeting
the rock on i mean i just i'm curious
i've never had anybody ask me it that
way but i think that's my normal
greeting
yeah i think it is you're just you're
just i i'm the most
awkward greeter and i know it and i try
and
when i try to be less awkward it just
becomes more awkward
i saw someone in the parking lot the
other day and they were so kind and they
said
hey are you john doloni and i said yeah
thanks for coming but that's not what i
said
i would did some weird like
it was the most awkw like i just want to
hug himself i'm sorry i love you this
whole i have a great awkward greeting
story for you
okay uh i shared this on my show
recently we do these funny work fails on
fridays yeah
and so one lady submitted that she was
walking into the office
do this whole show you could do funny
work fail so this lady's walking in the
office james you'll actually love this
and uh she's walking in and she's
walking in and a co-worker's
walking out of the door and um
he she says hey how you doing something
like that and he basically
combines the word how you doing and hey
and she thought he meowed at her
so we don't know what he said but her
recollection is that he went meow
and so in a moment of what do i do she
went meow
back at him to which he looked at her
like she was an alien because he clearly
hadn't meowed at her
so how about that the rest of her
working career with that guy
she's worried about what he's doing you
made a cat noise that was weird
so there you go good to see you he's
going to be in a meeting one day
and someone's going to put her picture
up on an overhead yeah an overhead
because this story takes place in 1974
yeah
they're going to put it up on a computer
screen and um
they're going to meow hey we should we
should promote her and he's gonna be
like
um she's a cat lady she is a cat lady
yeah so there you go we've all had those
moments here's the deal
don't sweat it don't worry about it uh
move on
shall we move on to the phones let's do
that triple eight eight two five
five hey come on that was fun james that
was fun
he's like we please get to the phones
james is actually um one of the
co-authors of
a really famous internet page called fun
ruiner dot com slash org he is
he is uh the spiritual gift of being a
wet blanket
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number
we love james james is amazing he's
always a bright spirit triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to atlanta
uh where we started off franklin is
joining us there franklin how can we
help
i'm doing well hope you guys are too um
john honor to talk to you you always
give sage advice and uh dig a little bit
deeper and hit the nail on the head
uh so just thank you thank you guys to
help me out today so what's up
um so my grandparents uh have it's
been their intention ever since i was
born to give me their house
that they have lived in uh they actually
built it um
it could have been on home and gardens
done a lot of acreage um
very beautiful but my grandfather has
since passed my grandmother is now 8-9
and it's in a lot of disrepair um
and furthermore that there's no use for
me to have this house it's you know an
hour away from where me my wife and my
family are currently living and it's
the amount of upkeep it would require as
almost a full-time job so there's just
no way i can keep it
uh but my grandma always tells me you
know now that she's getting at the end
of her life that's her you know intent
is to give me this house i'm in the will
to do it she actually wants to go ahead
and title it to me now
um but i don't have it in my heart
really to
uh tell her that i would you know i
would not plan on keeping this house my
intent would be to
to sell it unfortunately just because i
wanted to be a blessing and not a burden
so kind of having some issues dealing
with that
what is it
why can't you just take the house and
then when it comes time for you to make
decisions that are right for you and
your family at a later time
um you can make those decisions then
i can certainly do that and i think um i
guess my issue comes down to
you know she always asked me what would
i do with the house you know when it is
mine and i kind of you know shrugged my
shoulders you know i'm not really sure
yet i have to make a decision about that
later but in my heart i know we would
sell it so i just feel bad
i guess i don't say leading her on um
but i kind of just feel bad about you
know telling her or even just doing that
really and i think there's a lot of
equity issues too
where i've been kind of the golden child
of the family yep and there's a lot of
other grandkids you know there it is
that's what i was getting at this has
nothing to do with that house dude
you don't want to be that kid right
yeah i mean that's that's definitely
part of it i think the bigger part
really is i don't want to let her down
and i feel like i would be letting both
you know my late grandfather and her
down
by selling the property
i i i disagree with that um it may be a
conversation you have with the rest of
your family
um you're a grown-up you can do what you
want to with
a gift that somebody gives you if you if
it's a family home and it's a family
estate then clearly if you're going to
sell it then
you could um sell it for a dollar to
your cousin
right or to you could create a truck
there's a hundred different things you
could do with it
um it's it sounds like you're making it
a bigger ethical deal than
than it needs to be and if you think it
needs to stay in the family but you
don't want it
if you don't want to quote unquote
disappoint somebody that gave you a gift
then do what you want to do with it but
i don't see any reason why you need to
tell your grandma
um hey i'm not taking this gift like
she's eight how old is she
86.89 89 i mean i don't know it's it's
gonna be a gift to her to let her take
take the gift what do you think ken um i
don't disagree with what you're saying
john
but i would challenge you franklin if
you don't want the house
for the reasons that you don't want the
house it's not like her coming to your
birthday party when you're 11 and giving
your birthday present you're going i
don't want a birthday present from me i
think that's sting pretty hard
i think if you explain to her why you
don't want the house but you're honored
you're you're you're you're feeling all
the feelings and you say
grandma i don't want the house but i
don't hurt you i think it's simple you
got to put your big boy pants on and i
think there's a way to do that
um but i don't disagree with what john
said either i think you got to get over
either way you're gonna have to get over
disappointing
somebody there you go i think that's the
issue either i'm disappointed or i'm
worried about criticism from my siblings
or whoever else
uncle larry or the cousins uh or i'm
worried about grandma being disappointed
at some point
john i'm not gonna make a major life
decision that i don't believe i should
do
just because it might disappoint
somebody so i'm gonna be a little bit
tougher and go
put your big boy pants on franklin and
tell grandma the truth
i think she can handle it but be loving
yeah very respectful
in the process that's what i do and i'd
take the house
and we'll figure it out later that's why
i said i don't disagree but if he's
worried about his other stuff somebody's
got to make the decision hey
we got to get out of here more ramsey
show coming right up
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsey show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague
john deloney and we are here for you to
give you hope
to give you practical answers to help
you win
in all areas of your life so we're
talking about your money of course that
you've come to know and love
we're going to talk about your work i
specialize in helping you
get the income you want and the impact
that you want
working on purpose that's right and john
is going to help you on your life and
relationships
uh the mental emotional health as well
john and i like to combine
from time to time when we get these
calls john where folks are just in a
nasty professional situation
and it's got the relationship and
emotional component and the professional
component so we like those so i'm going
to put that out there if you've got a
pretty hairy situation at work
nasty culture maybe even some toxic
abusive leadership or co-workers
uh boy we like those we can tear those
apart so what does that show to your
kids is voltron
when they came together and they joined
their powers they became stronger
is that voltron james james help us out
thinking of captain planet captain
planet
no it was voltron but it's cool okay
captain planet they say our power is
combined so
yeah so we'll combine our powers is what
you're trying to care bears i think
yeah we'll do the professional and the
psychological the relational the
professional we'll do it all so there
you go
here's how you get in triple eight eight
two five five
two two five it is a toll-free number
triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to morgan now who joins us in fort
wayne indiana morgan
how can we help hi guys thanks for
taking my call
um i am so i will be 25 next month i
just left a two-year
relationship where i lived with my
boyfriend in his home so i had to move
back with my parents
not really ideal for my age i have no
debt at all and i really want to move
out
but with my current job salary i will be
living almost paycheck to paycheck
uh recently earlier this week i got a
new job offer that's almost
20 000 more a year but the schedule is
not something i would want to work
it's an off shift it's third shift and
then they said they might actually need
to move me to second shift possibly so
i'm a morning person i function best on
a normal
like work schedule normal sleep schedule
but this job would be the answer to my
prayers financially
so i'm just really having a hard time
deciding on what i should do
okay i think there's two clear options
here morgan and i'm fine with either one
john you may come up with a different
option um
one you take the new job and even though
it's not ideal for you
i didn't hear anything that's really
detrimental to your health
and it's a short-term play it gets you
out of mom and dad's house
fresh start after the two-year
relationship you got a lot of transition
going on
it may give you some mojo some juice a
fresh start
is it ideal no but is it the answer to
your prayers financially those were your
words so i like that option
and what we do is we take it and we have
an eye to the future looking for the
actual work we want to do and we use
this
as a springboard to the next okay and i
can address the next if you're
wondering what that is that's one option
the other option is you go all right
i just got a job offer for 20k more
but it's not ideal but it tells me i
am very marketable which is true and we
are in a great job market which is true
and you can hang out with mom and dad a
little bit longer and not be so ashamed
of being back with mom and dad at 25
after two year breakup i don't think
that makes you a loser
and if you need to lick your wounds and
get healthy i'm okay with you staying
with mom and dad until you find another
job
that may be more ideal i think those are
two clear decisions i don't have a
problem if you pass on this one
but i certainly don't think it's a a bad
idea to take it
and let it be the springboard to the
next
yeah morgan did your mom and dad like
this guy
uh no they did not at all okay so i
actually wrote that down um
it sounds like you are heartbroken
and relieved and living out of shame
yep you're embarrassed to be back at
your house is that fair your mom's house
uh
yeah a little bit so i think ken is
super wise
twenty thousand bucks is twenty thousand
bucks you take the job and rock it on
and you're not locked into this forever
thing
and the other side of it is which i
think's pro
i think's wiser is don't
don't live out of embarrassment choose
not to live out of embarrassment please
okay it sucks it is what it is you got
in the boxing ring and you got knocked
down it happens to a hundred percent of
boxers
yeah and you got knocked down and now
you're gonna stay at home you're
embarrassed you can even take your mom
and dad out to dinner and say
this is uh y'all were right and y'all
told me so dinner love it and
you can uh pay for everything and then
you can spend the next six months to a
year
saving your money up and then like ken
said find a perfect job for you
if you're worth twenty percent twenty
thousand dollars more now at this place
you're worth twenty thousand dollars
more at other jobs too yeah morgan i'm
just curious where do you wanna end up
do you know what the direction is um
not exactly so i have done a little bit
of college work
i stopped because i wasn't exactly the
short major i wanted to pursue and i'm
still kind of in that boat i don't
really feel like i have like
a dream job or a dream career to pursue
right now okay what are you wondering
about because i know somebody as sharp
as you you've had a couple of ideas and
i get being unsure
i want to know what the idea that keeps
popping up the most is
say it don't think okay um so
for a long time i've really wanted to go
into like the cosmetology esthetician
kind of beauty field but i've always
been you know knocked down and people
say you can't make very much money there
so
oh i can't stand those people yeah i
paid my barber yesterday
what'd you pay billion dollars yeah i
gotta tell you
i've got a couple of friends that own
cosmetology businesses and they're
crushing it
i'm so sick of they all right morgan i'm
so glad i asked you this
you thought you were getting out of this
call oh we're just getting started doc
all right morgan yes you listen to me
if i told you that you could make good
money enough money
and you could be very successful in the
cosmetology field
would you do it tomorrow yeah
what i want you to tell me the why what
draws you
to that think about the actual work
and result of the work
i think it's just always something i've
had a passion for and the idea of making
people
you know feel good after they're in your
chair or in your salon or your suite
makes me
like makes me feel good about that idea
and i've just always had
been drawn to that there it is yeah so
what if i
told you morgan that i think you were
created
with talents that are probably people
related and then creative related to
make
women feel beautiful and confident and
special and
if you don't do that you're not
impacting the people that you were put
on this planet to impact how does that
sound
sounds scary if i don't pursue it now
when you say it like that
well i don't want to scare you but i
want you to does your heart agree with
that statement forget about the fear
do you agree that that's something that
would make you feel very very full
yeah i think it would you notice there
was nothing in that john about
money no it was about impact meaning
do people bear their souls to you morgan
or do they bear their souls to people
that they're in the chair
getting loved on yeah
um john
do your parents tell you not to be an
esthetician
uh no they kind of they support me with
whatever
okay let's reframe your whole situation
you're 25 you're untethered you got rid
of an idiot
and you got free room and board for a
season to go get your licensure
yep and go start crushing it yeah and
i'm not even a guy that uses crushing it
kind of language because it sounds like
yeah bro like i've got big tires on my
truck and i don't
but i think you can crush it yep i think
you're right in the perfect season and
if you'll be graceful with yourself
take your mom and dad out have a
ceremony heaven i told you so dinner
y'all were right i'm 25.
way to go mom and dad and then turn that
sucker around
and use and tell them i need an 18-month
plan this is gonna be weird for all of
us i'll follow your weird rules
but you can go get it rent-free and they
can launch you out into the universe
with your certificate and then you go go
get it done man
yes morgan and morgan i want to take you
back to that moment on the call where
you said oh it feels scary ken if i
don't do it
i don't want that to be fear i want you
to feel though the responsibility i
think you felt the weight
that there are women in this world that
need to encounter morgan
what you think is making it feel
beautiful maybe the day that
makes them feel confident enough to make
their own big decision folks there's
purpose in every
piece of work i don't care if you're a
plumber 100 or you're a professor
yes oh good stuff morgan go do it and i
like staying with mom and dad a little
longer this is a beautiful bridge
don't be afraid to walk in all right
don't go anywhere
more life change more hope
or breakthrough coming up this is the
ramsey show
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm finn
coleman joined by my colleague
john delonia we're here with you this
hour taking your questions about life
john and i specifically we focus on our
shows by the way they're named after us
so you don't have to search real hard on
that we're on the ramsey network and
john and i are going to answer your
money questions as you come to expect
here on the ramsay show but we'll also
dive into our areas
i'm helping people figure out what they
were born to do you were created to work
in other words created to contribute so
i want to help you
get that bigger shovel make more money
get promoted so you can get out of debt
faster i also want you to make the
impact so
income and impact is what i'm focused on
of course john life and relationships
and the mental and emotional stuff
helping so many people who are hurting
he's going to untangle those difficult
relationships and difficult situations
so we're going to add that to the list
of calls
and john and i are here for you we'd
love to hear from you triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five hey
uh you need to find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
john in michigan he asked
i'm a mechanical engineer in the auto
industry making 100 000
a year my wife works for an airline and
earns 50 000.
we are debt-free other than our mortgage
and have a considerable amount in
savings
in our 401k and retirement accounts i
have an opportunity to take a job at a
startup company that would increase my
pay by 50
boy this just keeps getting better i
wonder if he's got a question in here
he's just telling us how good life is
uh the company is in green energy
and has contracts for at least the next
two years i've never worked for startup
before the work sounds exciting but what
are the things i need to consider okay
there we go
john now this is a bit of an onion
because the reality is we have no track
record
right so you can't go do your homework
and talk about culture and try to find
out i mean there's startups
i would i would try to find somebody who
works over there and do get an idea of
what the current culture is like we
don't have a track record but we can at
least say
what's the shared behavior over there
how do they act we can get that
i certainly would start there um
john but aside from that this is going
to come down to what i would call a
calculated risk i am not a fan of a
wee risk i'm just not unless you have
zero zero financial
issues and there is no financial risk in
your situation
you guys are making really good money
you're debt-free other than the mortgage
but you still got the mortgage
and so i would do the calculated risk
here and what i'm saying is
i would i would get down to it and i
would ask myself first of all
is this something that's in my sweet
spot now here's what i teach
you got to have the talent for it i mean
top talents
you got a love of the work the actual
task the role that you would fill
gotta love the work and then the results
of that work have got to connect to your
values you've got to be
missional those results matter deeply to
you if
you do that john and this job answers
those three questions yes
then i'm fine with it because the
reality is is that you got
an opportunity that if it goes crashing
down
you're not going to be tainted the rest
of your life you're in pretty good
financial situation you got the
emergency fund in place
and i would walk into that that's a
calculated risk if your heart's saying
yes after we qualify is it in my sweet
spot
if your heart's saying yes financially
this is not a big risk i'd do it
absolutely i say again i'm more of a
wee guy than you are i know um well i'm
okay with we
if there's zero financial implications
yeah well i think i
i i think there's gonna be some
financial implication but um
i don't see green energy investments
going away
and clearly he's on the front end of the
auto industry if they're trying to pull
him over there so he's a mechanical
injury that may be working on some of
the
the some of the new technology in auto
industry and so um if someone's going to
pull you over and increase your pay by
50
my my gut tells me is you're on the
front end of some stuff and you're good
at what you do
so if this thing goes away in two years
you'll be able to it doesn't work
it doesn't taint you yeah you can say
hey i went and took a shot at a startup
you've got a story you've got this
professional narrative
called your resume and experience and no
one's gonna shame you for that
and here's what i love i love that
you're taking your same
talent your same skill and you're
applying it to a different industry you
got the auto industry now you got the
energy industry
you're going to meet new people you're
going to find make new contacts you're
going to learn new
new a whole new industry i love that and
just quick review because we a lot of
people listen to the show and they're
new to you and me depending on what day
they listen
what i just said i want to review that
if you want to know whether or not you
should take a job beyond the financial
implications but you're going will i be
happy there
you've got to know if it's in the sweet
spot and that is where talent
what you do best hard skill soft skills
passion for the work you
love the actual task and role you've got
to really enjoy it
and then the results of the work have
got to set your heart on fire now that's
a
dream job but you got to run that
analysis john because when you do and if
you get yes
i'm talented i've got the talent yes i
love the work yes the results matter to
me
that is a ding ding ding stop thinking
about it your heart should be going
yes yes yes and then we make all the
other logical decisions is it a good
company culture
uh and is this a good move for me
financially but don't overthink this
folks that's a very simple construct so
there you go
844 excuse me that's the wrong number
that's my number john have you done that
yet when you've hosted the show
no because i memorized my number you
haven't memorized your number oh that's
nice on the board
when you memorize your number you got to
get back into this
i got that but i gotta pay attention
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number
let's go to sammy in chicago
sammy how can we help hi thanks for
taking my call
you bet what's up um so me and my
husband are on baby step four
but we need to build a fence to keep our
dogs safe so we're kind of torn between
that decision whether we just keep
throwing all the money towards the debt
or
because we eventually need to build this
fence because we have dogs that will run
so i'm just kind of torn between the two
and i don't know what would be the
wisest decision
okay you said baby step four okay which
one two sorry oh okay all right that's
what confused me
all right how much is going to cost to
uh how much is going to cost to build
the fence
um we've kind of calculated it out but
there's
just so many different materials but we
think it might be around fifteen hundred
to two thousand
okay where are the dogs now um they're
in their cage so
so they're not running out now i'm
trying to determine
they're they're in the house they're
inside dogs but when we take them out to
go to the bathroom
our yard isn't fenced in how much debt
do you got
yeah um we've got around 50 000.
what's your income how long what's
what's the repayment
projection for this um
we should have our debt paid off by
december
2023.
so john here's where i'm at this is it's
one of those things where can you
can you cash flow it can you sell
something and still stay on the
yes i think this is not that big of an
expense so if it's that big of a deal i
the thing that's throwing me off is the
dogs are already they're not running
away now so you're clearly taking them
out
with the leash you're just wanting to be
able to open the door not worry about
fido that's what this boils down to
yeah correct well we want to be able to
you know get them out there then um get
exercise play fetch with our dog
and to be able to smell things so they
they're kind of just put on the leash
and then
they just go to the bathroom so they
don't really get a lot of like outdoor
times are very energetic
i totally understood what if i told you
to sell your dogs oh jesus
it wouldn't happen okay so that hey
that's what i wanted to know and i was
i was testing you because if you said
well we thought about it then i would
tell you to go sell your dogs but if
like your response no i'd really get rid
of my husband first
um go build a fence yeah build the
physical defense and sleep fine yeah
cash flow
you're probably better off these days
building it out of gold than of with
lumber because lumber cost a million
dollars a fence board but go ahead and
get
build your fence yeah call it good don't
lose a second to sleep over it
if you borrow money i'm going to tell
dave on you he's out of town
i'm going to tell him he's going to come
to your house i'm going to email him
right now that you're
not going to do this so he puts the
pressure on you yeah borrowing money
wasn't it wasn't an option
we have cash where we just don't know
whether to put it towards the debt or
for the fence pay for the fence get
right back on the stove but don't let
this be
the slippery slope yep where you're like
well let's go ahead and uh
we need tacos tonight too and we need to
go ahead and get new windows and while
we're at it
hey don't do that this can be a slippery
slope pay for the fence you need it and
then move on with your life
yep you can do this you're you're listen
you're on track you got the budget
you're knocking stuff out
this is just an adjustment get through
it but john's right
better be disciplined and you know what
i don't want to go outside at midnight
and let rover pee
i get it it makes a lot of sense you
ever had a puppy in the middle of winter
yeah it's so fun john defense is huge
vince is big i like the festival
you sell your dogs that's a good
decision zelda dogs i can't believe you
said that you horrified the poor lady
and me by the way boy did i bite on that
man
you had me like a fish on a hook wow hey
don't move
john delaney ken coleman here on the
ramsay show coming right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right welcome back to ramsay show
coming to you america from our ramsay
solutions headquarters in nashville
thrilled to have you with us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
is the toll-free number to jump in i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague
john delonia we're taking your questions
about life so dial it up you got the
money questions you got
you got the relationship questions you
got the hey man i want to make some more
money i
i want to i want to move up the ladder a
little bit we'll talk about it
all and specifically john and if you've
got a particular hairy situation at work
that involves some relationships and the
professional stuff john and i like to
take
on those together so we'll take those by
the way kelly will change your name
and your location if you've got a
particularly sensitive situation i want
to point this out
we want you to feel safe to be able to
call us
and talk through something and not worry
maybe about your employer realizing
you're talking about them or whatever so
just want to put that out there we'll
take good care of you kelly is the best
in the business triple a eight two five
five two two five
is the number let's go to brianna or
brianna i never know we're about to find
out john it's kind of like tomato tomato
i don't know we'll find out austin texas
is where she is
brianna is it brianna did i get
brilliant
fantastic all right how can we help
today hey ken hey dr d
uh this one is actually going to be
directed mainly to dr d
today i'm so happy you're on and i just
appreciate both for all of you for
everything you guys do um so dr dalony
uh two weeks ago my mom tried to kill
herself
i'm so sorry and thank you this has been
like so hard um i'm in texas now i used
to live in california so she
is in california and she had posted on
facebook
a really disturbing like post pretty
much saying goodbye
and i happened to just see it and so i
freaked out this is she tried doing this
when i was in my 20s
um so this isn't the first time and
nobody knew where she was
um so it was a situation where she had
done something
but nobody knew where she was she turned
off her phone
and so i'm at work trying to call her
and reach out and she's on facebook and
she's able to message me and she's
literally saying goodbye to me
like saying her goodbyes through
messenger so by the grace of god
one of my co-workers figured out a way
using facebook
and we found her we found her location
and sent the police to her
they had gotten her just in time and she
took a ball of pills and drank a bottle
of whiskey and was not in good condition
when they found her
so it's been really hard um
i just my question is like i just i have
so many different emotions because my
whole life
dr d i felt like the mom i have felt
like i've been the mother she abused
drugs
you know she's a long time so she has a
lot going on
how do i how do i
talk to her without like
i'm angry i'm sad like how do i have
conversations without
i don't want to enable her because i
don't her behavior is just
it's just out of it's too much and i'm
just worried she's going to do it again
but i love my mom
yeah how do i deal with it i think
there's
there's two things you're you're working
through dealing with
one is a lifetime of exhaustion
and baggage and anger and heartbreak
all those things and what i would tell
you is those things are yours to deal
with
okay those things it's it feels like it
would be
so good to sit across from your mom in a
diner and let her have it
yeah and it wouldn't right
that's between you and your counselor
okay
if you haven't already growing up in the
home of an ad
growing up in the home of someone who
tries to hurt themselves growing up in
somebody
where you've had to parent your parent
um
that is trauma on top of trauma on top
of trauma
and what i'll tell you is not by your
hand but in your lap you didn't ask for
it you didn't
your house is flooding and it's because
your neighbor's um
pipe broke at the end of the day you got
to deal with your house right
so this will roll down through your
um lineage this trauma unless you stare
it down
go sit with a counselor and say this
stops with me okay
my guess is you've got your own
controlling
i bet you and i could talk for an hour
on your remarkable um
non-addict addictions is that is that
true yes
100 i'm the total opposite of my mom
independent
very close to god like just i'm just the
total opposite and i'm so blessed
and i've gone through this it's made me
so strong such a strong woman
sometimes our opposites become
addictions too
right right and so all to say is this
you'd go deal with that as a as in terms
of your mom
here's here's a couple of ways i
describe this and and you gotta
understand like i've done funerals
for young people i've hugged too many
moms and too many dads i've been there i
get it it's
the it's it's unlike anything else
um my son if he came
in in the middle of the night tonight
and he walked into my room
and he said daddy i don't feel good and
i sat up and said what's wrong buddy and
he just barfed all over me
i could be frustrated that my kid barfed
on my bed i could be annoyed that it's
2am and i've got to change my sheets and
all that kind of stuff
but i wouldn't be angry with him i
wouldn't be pissed off at him
because he's hurting and he went to the
place
the only place he knew that would help
him that the hurt stop
and that's somebody he loves that's his
dad right that's his mom
and so being angry about somebody trying
to hurt himself is like being angry at
somebody for being
not well okay it's frustrating it's
annoying god such a beating it's
such a beating and you're dealing with
somebody that's
that's sick they're not well okay so
there's a some remarkable research has
come out the last few years
i always thought um and i do this for a
living i always thought that if you
tried to hurt yourself and
somebody helped you out you would just
figure out a way to do it later
right that it's inevitable the research
says that's absolutely false
absolutely false people who
make some hard choices in their life i
want to get the care i want to
not be feel like a burden to anybody i
don't want to hurt myself i want to have
value i don't want to be lonely
that you can heal from that the
challenge for people who love folks in
the situation is a decision they've got
to make themselves
and so for your mom less about hey this
and that you need to
it's i love you i love you i have loved
you i do love you here's my boundaries
to keep me well
what can i do to help and then you've
got to decide what your boundaries are
and then at the end of the day your
mom's going to make your mom's choices
but we want to surround her with
opportunities we want to surround her
with phone numbers we want to surrender
with people who care
to the best of our ability right and at
the end of the day
it's terrifying but that's what you can
do you can love really hard and really
well
yeah you know john i i i hear this and i
there's only so much she can do you
gotta have those boundaries but at some
point you realize i
can't do it i can't change mom right
there's a big pressure i mean i'm
assuming there's huge pressure on
brianna and other people that go through
that
absolutely it's like it's like what what
can i do
and then you feel like i'm going to go
help mom and at some point mom
as hard as this is mom's got to help
herself well
decide to well yeah he's going to make a
choice to take help
yeah and so she did a brave thing um and
this is how i know that
brianna's a brave strong
healing woman and um
somebody not to be reckoned with in a
good way she called 911 on her mom i
know
too many people who wouldn't do that
right i don't want to call the cops i
don't want to get them involved
no that's the right thing to do and so
here here's here's what i'm going to do
i would fly out and sit with my mom if i
could if i can afford that i'd fly out
and sit with my mom
and let her know that i love her let her
know that i would love to connect with
her in any way possible
make sure she's got a num numbers to
call people in her life
uh make sure that her local church local
community her husband whoever is around
her
is in on this um
and then i would make sure i'm taking
care of me yeah i i got to tell you
i thought that was incredible and i
think more people need to hear what you
just said
because what happens when you when
you've got a loved one or a friend so
let's call it a family member friend
that you care deeply about and they are
hurting themselves yeah and you're
trying to do everything you can to stop
it or help it or whatever
at some point it almost becomes
obsession even though it's coming from a
good place it gets really unhealthy and
all the hurt and pain and frustration
you're dealing with ends up making it
worse
if you knock yourself out you're of no
good anybody if you're not
any good right if you're not well and
that's hard you got to deal with your
stuff yeah it's hard to let go
long enough to get healthy yeah and
nobody wants our um
so nobody wants our moms our loved ones
our friends to hurt themselves so
again hear hear what i'm saying it's not
inevitable no there
is healing people have to make hard
choices and you want to surround them
with emergency care if you can
that's tough tough tough when you're an
adult
big thanks to my colleague john delaney
always fun hanging with you pal
really good stuff i want to thank our
producer james childs our associate
producer kelly daniel but mostly we want
to thank
you america for listening this is about
you
you can do it you have what it takes
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life i'm ken coleman
joined by john doloni as we take your
calls this hour it is a free
phone call toll free triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight two five five two two five we
combine
uh our forces we're both ramsey
personalities if you're new to the show
or new to us
dr john deloney show is on the ramsey
network where he talks to you about life
and relationships mental emotional
health
the ken coleman show also on the ramsey
network where i talk to you about
discovering what you were born to do
what is that professional purpose
that unique contribution where you make
the income you need and the impact you
want so we're here to help in those
areas as well
we love to be together we're having a
blast so let's go
waiting on you triple a eight two five
five two two five let's go to houston
texas
where we start off with rick rick how
can we help
i just had a question on when you go to
what store like a department store
or a sporting goods store and you make a
purchase
and they offer you a discount to open a
line of credit how do you
address that situation no thank you take
credit
no thank you never just say no thank you
yeah never never but i mean there's a
discount you know i'm saying
okay so let's play that out so you're
super smart rick
and you decide to well i'm gonna game
these folks
i'm gonna sign up for their uh
sports stores rs card and get
15 off on the baton helmet for my kid
you know i'm feeling really good about
myself
and then you gotta immediately go to the
parking lot and cut the cart up and call
them
and get out of is that what you're going
to do right
see there's a big temptation there so
we've been pretty consistent for a long
time on this john and we're kind of
adopting this from dave
that now you've got yourself a credit
card opened and if you don't close it
there's all kinds of options there to
get into a hole
all right thoughts yeah he's not buying
it
john he's not this was the big
revelation for me rick and i'm with you
i love feeling like i'm gaming the
system it's one of my favorite things to
do i love it i especially love it when
somebody thinks i can't game the system
and then i can show them i can i love it
right
um it's when i realized this those guys
aren't my friends
and they're not div it's not like hey
bro hey help me out here open up this
card and i'll give you this discount
they are willing to take
less money on the front end because
their data tells them
that they over the long game are better
at this than me
and what i realized over the long game
is i canceled it i cancelled it i
cancelled it i cancelled it and then
once i didn't
and whatever that one was turned into
another thing and then i got a an
advertisement in the mail i was like oh
man they're running a big sale over here
suddenly i'm buying stuff i've got money
out there and listen
i ever people listening is like i would
never do that cool high five you
but then no company gives away money
because they're your friends
yep no airline gives you miles because
they're nice to you
dick you know what you've helped us out
we're gonna help you out they're doing
that because they make
money yeah the numbers prove it rick so
you asked should you do it we told you
no yeah if you want to do it and you can
be disciplined
you're grown you're a grown-up rick you
can do what you want you're a big boy
what i'm telling you is
you will lose the game in the long run
and they know that
that's why they offer it to you we're
not going to say it's okay for you rick
but not for other people who call the
show because
they fall prey to the trap i think rick
the ricks of the world i got friends
like this still ask me this question
of the world well but i get friends who
are very smart financially
yeah and they know i work with ramsey
solutions they do this to me all the
time it's like a party trick
i'm not kidding yeah it's like guys
listen i didn't say you were morally
wrong for doing it i'm not saying that
you aren't disciplined enough to do it
what we're telling you is the answer has
to be no because so many people aren't
yeah so what are we supposed to say you
know what rick
you can actually do it but the rest of
you don't do it well and that's the
other side of it is
when i let's say i can't figure it out
i can be that one person the one out of
however
that's it then i realized wait a minute
this company makes their
billions and billions of dollars
on the backs of frightened people scared
people
exhausted people people who are in a
crunch
i don't want to support that right i
don't wanna i don't wanna contribute to
that so i'm just gonna opt out
right and i'll pay an extra seven
dollars on my
whatever purchase at whatever sporting
goods store because
to not get into that game with them all
right john i've got
breaking news break it brand new data
on generation z and it's got a
relational component okay
bring it so i share it on my show today
but i want to get your take on it okay
because i know you have some great
insight here it is
new data new poll by generation lab they
researched a bunch of college students
and recent graduates so we're talking
about generation z
folks okay so these are people that are
in high school
college and now they're there's early
20s in the workforce
gen z and you're ready for this john a
whopping 40
of college students and recent grads
prefer
to work in the office
all the time not remote work
okay now this is amazing another
39 of those ages in generation z
are okay with a hybrid so they're in the
office and some flexibility
but i want to focus on the 40 because
here's what they said
they said that they're concerned about
missing out on relationships
and mentoring so community in the office
where i make connections out of
relationships which gives me the
opportunity by the way
to move up the ladder and mentorship
those were the two specifics that the 40
percent
who said we want to work full-time in
the office now
i'm going to get you to weigh in on this
because i find this to be not
shocking but this is with 12 percent
of the current workforce non-gen z the
rest of them millennials and up
12 are saying we'll go back to the
office full time
the rest want to work from home or
certainly hybrid
so this is coming out of the pandemic
where remote work is now
dominating people are not wanting to go
back to work when they're being asked or
they're going no i'll quit my job and
deal with the whole job hunt rather than
go back full time
but these young people john i was
thrilled way to go
they're seeing it why do relationships
matter they're not seeing it they're
all they're feeling it well thank you
and you see that though they're seeing
so
they want relationships i noticed this
um so i i got pretty nihilistic
in 2010 2011. i was a part of some
at university where they were piloting
they were handing all these students
iphones and hitting them all ipads and
i began to watch them you know staring
at these we watched it before it became
what it is now
and it was remarkable to see in short
order
young people playing games when they
would all go out to dinner
and they would say hey everybody puts
their phone over here the first person
who grabs it buys dinner
they started self-solving this problem
because they grew up
10 years 15 years for most of us this is
new
right this is five years seven years 10
years old this is their whole life
and what they realized is i am missing
everything more importantly is i sleep
better i'm connected i
learn more you stuck me in front of a
screen schools in universities for the
last 15 years and i learned
nothing i got no relationships i got no
profit i got nothing
here's the other thing they know that
relationships are
how they learn how they move up they
want people to pour into them they also
said in this study john that they
want their leaders to give them feedback
face to face
eyeball to eyeball so there is a craving
there that is not new
to who we are folks we are relational
human beings i'm not poo pooing remote
work but leaders pay attention
gin z may save the in-office workplace
john shocking
all right they're gonna go create their
owns what they're gonna do that's great
more of your calls coming up this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ramsay show continues i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
john deloney and we are here for you
triple eight eight two five
five taking your questions about life
taking your questions about your work
and
purpose taking questions about
relationships taking questions about
money i mean we're just talking about
the whole thing and so we're here for
you always excited to be with my
colleague dr john delooney
and if you want to check him out the
doctor john delaney show new episodes
every monday
wednesday and friday on youtube and
anywhere you listen to potly and you
listen rather
to podcast this book is redefining
anxiety you can get it on amazon
ramseysolutions.com anywhere books
are sold at his website johndaloney.com
all right let's get to the photos triple
eight eight two five five two
two five let's go to bend oregon where
tierra
joins us tierra how can we help
hi thank you for taking my call you bet
i had a question about bringing in
income as a single mom with three kids
um my husband recently passed away
man so sorry tara how long ago
uh may 29th oh my goodness
what happened here um he
he was diagnosed with colon cancer
and um it was pretty quick it was about
um he was diagnosed last october and
um and he passed away in may so
yeah oh how old are your kids hun
um five three and almost one
do you have immediate family around you
i do
um i'm actually staying with um
my husband's parents okay so i just want
to stop and
just say i'm so sorry yeah
this isn't supposed to be that way and
you know that we know that and i'm so so
sorry
um thank you we're all able to
have a service and a funeral i know some
parts of the country still haven't
opened up completely
yeah yeah we um we were able to
have a memorial service at a local
church and
um it was it was a real blessing
good it was it helped
that time there was the hardest
you know the hardest moments of your
life and i want you to
rest assured that over the next few
months and years
that time will become sacred it'll
become holy time and
i'm glad y'all did that um so
what is your what is the reality the
math problem here the financial
situation that you find yourself
in yeah um so
i guess the main
the the the issue that
brings me to asking about generating
incomes
is really housing we live in a red hot
market
as i know you know and
it's just crazy here and
originally my husband and i were we were
saving
for a house and um we don't have any
debt
um but we were camp hosting um
it was a lot of fun actually and we were
just
putting money away and doing our camp
hosting and
then he got his diagnosis and that kind
of turned everything on its head
um so i am getting some money from
social security
um and he did have a life insurance
policy
um not a not a massive policy but
um it is contestable so i don't know if
that will come through or not
who's going to contest it well
he got the policy
last february and he started
experiencing
some symptoms some of his symptoms in
may um which led to him looking
you know looking into the doctor um but
he had had
some ongoing symptoms prior to that that
weren't
it weren't wasn't enough to drive him to
sleep
um oh gosh so the insurance company is
going to contest it i thought you're
talking about he's gonna have a family
member come out of the woodworking no no
no no no no
no i'm sorry but let me ask you this
tear and we'll get to your income stuff
here but this is so important
um do you have a sense are you just
worried about this are you getting
indicator
indicators that the insurance company is
going to contest it or are you just
concerned that they will
they wouldn't send me a copy of his
policy
wow um and so
i decided before i submitted the
application i would go see
an attorney that was recommended by
another attorney
and i wanted to have an attorney walk me
through the process before i even sent
them anything
good good all right so let's from a math
standpoint let's look at this
uh both ways what if they if you get the
full insurance
payout what would it be his life
insurance
a hundred thousand okay a hundred
thousand so we're gonna look at
variables here
with the hundred thousand without
because we got to figure out the plan
what's the social security payment per
month coming to you
500 about 3 500 okay
yeah and uh how much money had you all
saved for a house down payment
well we had some from a house that we
had sold
so um that would be not including
investments uh retirement accounts
um and the emergency fund
our savings is a hundred and ten
thousand okay great
okay um
what's the situ okay so income i mean
with the kids being the age they are
have you even first of all this is so
fresh so you don't have to have all this
figured out but
how i mean you need to take some time on
this but
but we've got to figure out the child
care situation or if you're going to
work from home even with you working
from home sweetheart it's going to be
hard with those kids that age so
we've got to be very realistic about the
type of work that you can get
that you can actually do and so there's
going to have to be some child
distraction is my point in the form of
child care
and i think you're going to have to
figure that out because i
i don't want to put you go from extreme
trauma and pain
into tremendous frustration and
desperation because it's gonna be very
hard to work at home with three little
ones without
child care you've thought through that
yes or no
right what do you have a solution there
well uh my mother-in-law i'm living with
my in-laws
um at the moment and so um
my my they've been great by the way
they've been really supportive
really awesome um all of my family
um in the eight families in the area and
um so but i don't
i i guess i i would want to
factor the cost of child care into the
equation because i wouldn't want to
just completely be dumping my kids on
family all the time
if that makes sense i totally get it so
let's back up for just a moment you get
you're getting 3 500
a month in social security payment and
if i understood this right you were
living in a camp
kind of hosting a camp so you have
little to no expenses right now other
than
food and clothing insurance stuff for
the
kids so i really want you you know i
don't know how long you've been
listening to the ramsay show
but you really putting together an
operating budget based on the 3 500
and and just quick snapshot do you feel
pretty comfortable that's going to take
care of basic expenses for you i would
imagine that it is
while you're still living with family
right yeah right oh yeah it will more
than take care of
any expenses i have no debt or car
payments or anything like that
yeah i got dave in my head john and i
know you said this is too soon to make a
big decision like this
let's see how long we can camp out with
family in the area and not worry about
job and income
let's get that figured out and then the
job whether you work from home
or you go back out of the workforce you
got time you got 110 grand in the bank
i'd take your time
were you gonna was your plan to be a
stay-at-home mom
yes um i i i planned the home
the original plan has always been and
i'm committed to
homeschooling our kids so here's the
thing here's the thing
this is what kim's talking about with
time
you need six months nine months here's
the deal those commitments and those
plans
have absolutely changed
and you can stick to your principles you
can stick to your guns
but everything in your home is different
now and that's what time the next three
months five months six months are going
to
get you is understanding that you're
going to get there you're going to have
some family support
and then you start deciding what comes
next take your time
stay with family healing will come now
we're so sorry
that you're in good shape breathe
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman join by
my colleague
dr john deloney and uh doc this is fun
i've been hearing the news around the
office it's popping up all over
social you got some fun stuff coming
i've got a fun event
you and uh are you and ray ray teaming
back up again yes me and rachel cruz so
we're six months
after the end of what was 2020
and everyone said now we'll just quote
unquote get back to normal
and our marriages are going to go back
to just the way they were
and if you're like me i don't know how
yours y'all are doing
we all just tried to get it all back in
one month or two and it's just turned to
an exciting time for marriages so that's
one way of putting it
that's the nicest way i could say this
on public radio
so rachel cruz and i this friday night
july 16th
join me and rachel for a money and
marriage live stream event this is all
new content
all new stuff we're going to teach you
how to navigate the top challenges
married couples face today when it comes
to money
relationships sex what to do next you'll
learn how to get clear on what you need
from your partner how the two of you can
have better conversations
what y'all can do next for all your
ramsay plus members you have access to
this event as part of your ramsey plus
membership if you're not a ramsey plus
member the money and marriage live
stream
is on sale for 30 bucks that's a date
that's it go to ramseysolutions.com
marriage y'all y'all can have a great
date learn about each other
i'm going to give you some tools we're
actually going to be some tools that's
going to help your marriage
get over where it's at now and really
accelerate into awesomeness yeah down
the road now i'm glad you mentioned that
it's a date because i want people who
are hearing this to go
okay a marriage event on a friday night
no no this will be fun
yeah oh it's a blast it's hilarious you
and rachel have great
fun personalities i know these folks
personally they're a lot of fun and it
comes
out in the event it really is fun and of
course
very practical and hopeful and guys can
i speak to dudes for a second
you're an idiot if you don't do this
this is a great way to win with the wife
hey babe i signed us up for a great fun
event
so i want to do better hey that's a win
why wouldn't you do that rachel cruz and
i want to learn how to be a better
husband i thought and guys i'm going to
set you up 30 bucks
i'm setting you up to win just trust me
yeah would you just show up and take
notes yes
and wives
just say hey we're doing this just say
we're doing this yeah i can't guilt the
wives i can i can guilt the dudes that's
right
you don't need to be guilty it's good
stuff this is an easy win lots of laughs
lots of fun
it's gonna be fun we're gonna have a
blast it is gonna be fun all right let's
get to the phones
john the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five mike is in cl oh
dude the home of the rock and roll hall
of fame
am i right about this cleveland ohio all
right mike
what's up hello
hi dr john hi dr john and ken how are
you well we're having a blast what's up
very good i'll make this quick for you
i'm 32 and my wife is 31
we're in baby steps four five and six
and we have an annual income of two
hundred and twenty thousand
well we have one child and i currently
have one more on the way
and over the next year or so we'd like
to buy a new car for myself so the
current car i've been driving has been
paid off
for the last 10 years that i've owned it
and i would like to get something bigger
so we've been saving on the side knowing
that we'd like to make this
purchase and can obviously be able to
pay cash for it
but the vehicle i'd like to purchase
used is still about 50 to
60 000. it doesn't break dave's 50
percent rule but i'm still having some
heartburn
about writing a check for that kind of
money um
towards just a vehicle and not putting
it towards that four five and six
how much do you have saved
uh probably about 45 already so you're
really close
so you got your emergency fund funded
you don't have any consumer debt
and you just got an emergency fund and
no consumer debt whatsoever
and you met dave's ratio of the
percentage so john this is psychological
here i've
turned this one over to you what kind of
car do you want
uh a gmc denali or a cadillac escalade
oh man these are
fine machines jeffy he's bawling and
shot calling with 20-inch blades
hey so what do you do for a living man
uh i work in government service and my
wife is a human resources manager
okay buy the car yeah so i i'm a bad guy
to ask and here's why
the car i drive in 06 right now i love
it it's just putting along
um my wife drives to 2010. she actually
said the other day for christmas could
we
for god's sake please my son is about
eight feet tall now and he looks like
fred flintstone in the car
um so i'm not a great person to ask i'm
like you if i've got forty thousand
dollars and i'm sitting there staring it
down to ride it that would be hard
on the other side of it um yeah the
ratios work out in your favor you make a
great salary you have no debt
um you're working four five and six and
you've saved up cash to buy this car
um what is what's making you what's
holding you back
uh the thought of the interest and next
16 to 18 years of what that money put
towards uh putting the kids through
college could do
so just do a thought experiment so
what's it like buying a forerunner
do you feel like a failure or a loser
you know are you going to need a car
eventually well let's say we don't buy
this now and you put that money in a
great investment
portfolio and it's making all that
interest that you're laying awake at
night
being guilty over at what point do you
need to get a car anyway at some point
you need another car yes or no
eventually but what i have now i could
probably ride out usually for a few more
years
i get it so i said this is one of those
things john where this is
there's no right or wrong here yeah go
with your heart man don't feel guilty if
you go by a nice car
don't feel guilty for a second if you
hold on to that money don't feel guilty
but you know what though i'm gonna i'm
gonna have some fun here with mike the
other day mike
you're not doing anything wrong here you
saved up for this you're really really
close but i why don't you
meet yourself in the middle for one more
scenario and you've probably done this
but i'm going let me look at what 25 is
gonna get me
and then i take the other 20 and i
invest that
have you done that i have yeah
i haven't looked too much but i thought
about the same thing all right
point is there's no right or wrong you
can't lose here man
follow your heart you're a good man by
the way congratulations let's not move
too quickly past the fact that you make
really good money
and you're in baby steps four five and
six and you've saved
forty five thousand dollars for a
replacement car
mike relax stop beating yourself up dr
john there's got to be something else
here man i think there's more than just
the interest
i think he's worked so hard to save up
money
and walk through the baby steps and he's
looking at that check and he's going
if i write a check that big i just feel
like a jerk
yeah well it's it's that we see this all
the time
absolutely and i stru i mean i'll tell
you i'm not gonna get it i struggle with
it
get it you're like who am i to be
driving a car with x y and z you're
somebody who freaking earned it and
somebody who paid for it and saved up
and struggled and sacrificed that's
right
what about that part john for those of
us who
who practice self-flogging on a regular
basis
we don't think about the positive side
right well true and i think there's some
of us that may be a little tougher boy
am i the worst
i mean i'm rough we've talked about that
but i also think this isn't just self
flogging this is also
discipline yeah and then he's going if i
spin this
on a really nice car i think he feels
frivolous
as opposed to frugal right and he's
going the frugal call
is to invest all this it messes with the
identity he's cultivated to protect
himself which is
i'm disciplined i don't need i've got a
10 year old car and it's hard to roll
out of that right say that one more time
i said that identity he's cultivated
protects him from himself
which is i'm frugal i don't have to do
those things that those people do and
suddenly you look up and you're making
250
000 and uh oh you're one of those people
it turns out
those are good people too they're great
people also
the reason i asked you to repeat that
that was that was haunting
i think that's right on you know when
you get gazelle intense you do take on
an identity
you have to you have to and then the
shedding of that identity when you get
out of there boy that is tougher we hear
it all but i've never heard you
say that yeah i've never heard it put
that way but boy that is tough to take
off that one mask or that hat
if you we're not implying that you're
not being authentic but this idea of
i've been in this this is who i've been
and all of a sudden i can be this other
person
that feels like my childhood we didn't
have a lot growing my parents worked
their butts off we didn't have anything
i created an identity which was i would
never be that person i would never buy a
car like that
and now suddenly why why have i spent my
life judging this
quick question if you could afford it in
the ratio everything that he could
you almost have to do it to shed the old
identity yes or no
i i i i'm not saying that's what i would
tell somebody if i was coaching them
i think you have to do it yeah you have
to yeah and of course this is said with
the fact that he can
that's right that's right don't forget
that all right he is john dolone i'm ken
coleman and you're listening to the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney and we're taking
your calls this hour of course about
your life and your money but
we kind of specialize in our area john
is in relationships and life and that
mental and emotional
component to the journey and i'm helping
you figure out
what were you born to do why are you
just working
if it's just for a paycheck i want to
help you go from paycheck to purpose
so we'll take those calls if you've got
a toxic situation a leadership situation
it's kind of nasty we love to take on
those together
and uh so we'll take them uh whoever you
are wherever you are whatever you got
going on we're here for you triple eight
eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five john i know you and i
are both super proud of our colleague
christy wright who's a national
bestselling author and of course
uh colleague as a ramsay personality and
oh man she's been working hard on an
awesome awesome new project
and it is her latest book take back your
time
the guilt-free guide to life balance and
it is now
available for pre-sale this book came
out of chrissy's real life struggles for
years she was running on empty and
stretched way too thin
why because wow she was a mom of three
is a mom of three
and she knew that something had to
change so she dug deep
and figured out where she was being
overwhelmed how she was over committing
and she discovered the balance is about
doing the right things at the right time
and you get to decide what's right for
you so this is not a product of
i can't say that john so it's certainly
not that it's not a productivity book
you got it i didn't throw my microphone
on yeah it's not one of those
lame yeah how to get balanced and find
the right
circles or triangles this is a no bs
no bullcrap this is like
how to get your time and your life back
step by step plan for intentionality
where you really do
yes feel like you are in control of your
time we all have
way more than we realize so we want you
to stop living burned out
and feel balanced go to the online store
at ramseysolutions.com
that's ramseysolutions.com pre-order
your copy of chrissy's new book take
back your time today
and when you do you're going to get over
50 of free bonus items we're really
proud of christine this is really really
good stuff
so dudes out there yeah you got the wife
with the multiple kids one kid it
doesn't matter
do you do you do yourself a favor by
doing your
wife a favor get it yourself it works
this is i've got to read this book this
isn't a female
no it's not a female-based book but guys
hey trust me i got listen we had three
kids
summer's busier than the school year oh
man because the life is driving the kids
all over the place so
you know there's so much goodness in
this for men for women it's just
really really great if you're feeling
like you're not controlling your time
very well so congratulations to christy
on that triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to elijah who
joins us in traverse city michigan
elijah how can we help hey
thanks for having me on guys you bet
what's up
um i'm having difficulty with an
inconsistent income
hey elijah sorry to interrupt you buddy
can you just maybe uh
adjust that phone a little closer to
your mouth and see if we can hear you
better you're a bit muffled
is this better not really let's try one
more time
i love this uh we'll try to make it work
john's younger than me and his ears are
better so we've got that going for us
what do we got for you um
um as a teenager i have an inconsistent
income right now
and i'm having trouble budgeting it
you're a teenager with an inconsistent
income and you're having trouble
budgeting what are you budgeting for
uh just you know saving spending giving
okay tell us what this is give us a
range of income
how inconsistent is it maybe give us a
top in low end in a given month
i make at least a um bucks a month but i
mean
it could go anywhere i mean i work for
myself during
um all the detail stuff
did you say auto detailing yes sir
okay so i'll tell you what i think we
got enough here having a hard time
hearing you
um so as a teenager john
i mean he doesn't have many expenses
other than what i heard saving for
probably maybe future car
college and he's got some spending
making a thousand bucks a month yeah
so uh the advice i would give on this uh
young man
is you gotta base it on what i would
call a median and i'd go to the low end
of the media so if
let's say over the last three to six
months is where i would start
and you know your auto detailing
business and i would go
high month and look at a low month kind
of average them together you know how to
do that and
okay this is probably a moderate
projection let's go on the low end so
let's just say it comes out to be a
thousand bucks
is your average over the last three to
six months i would budget off of that
and and that again is adjustable my
friend so if you have a month where you
only bring in 600
it's not the end of the world your mom
and dad are taking care of all your
expenses
you just adjust the budget each month
and i love that you took the time to
call the show that tells me you're a
very earnest young man you're very
serious
very disciplined this is a great
experience for him
if he eventually becomes an entrepreneur
where you have if you're a straight
commissioned salesperson we've coached
people on this for
many many decades here on the show that
uh that
income is fluctuating and so you have to
kind of ride the wave a little bit
by being very very disciplined for a
while
until you get stable enough in your
situation stability's not the issue
you just want to be smart so you get a
low month adjust the spending percentage
got a higher month want to spend a
little bit more great be very consistent
on the saving though
there you go i like that consistency on
the savings yeah and then everything
else kind of
rolls around that but hey thanks for the
call elijah really proud of you i hate
that we couldn't hear him very well
i would love to know more about what
he's doing i love when we get calls from
teenagers
these are the these are the they're
raring they're like i want a little bit
more
i i worked really hard as a teenager
with the one goal
of spending it all that weekend and then
starting again the next week and i dare
not ask
what you were spending that on let's go
to jordan in columbus ohio
jordan how can we help hey guys uh nice
talking to you today thanks for taking
my call you bet
and my question has to do with
relocating i uh i'm wondering
is it is it wrong to move um to a
different state just because you don't
particularly like the state that you're
living in
no um no move
all right that's a good answer so far um
i've been in columbus now for about five
years i
i grew up around mountains and around
the ocean and
kind of wanted to get back to an
environment more like that
for a while now but i do have three kids
and i'm married
and there's you know the relationship
aspects and you know
friends and family so jordan if you if
you are miserable at your home
the people who wear that the most are
your wife and your children
and so you can say hey you can you can
be a martyr
and say i'm just staying put for them
or you can sit down with your wife and
say i miss the mountains
i miss the ocean i miss living in a
place where i feel alive or i can take
our boys fishing or i can go hiking or i
can do all these things
and i would love to create a plan that
doesn't have to happen today
but a plan the next six months the next
year the next two years that will get us
back there
jordan have you sat down and had that
conversation
yeah and what is your wife's position
well my wife my life is more about the
relationships
than the place and i understand that and
i wouldn't say i'm miserable
i'm okay does she have does she have
family in columbus
yes do you have family in columbus no
ah now we're getting into a marriage
conversation here yeah
yeah i yeah listen this is this is a
marriage conversation you got to cast a
vision
john i'll let you come in and the finer
points here we only have about a minute
but
you got a cast vision as to why she's
got to get on board with your vision you
can't force her into this that's not a
good move
absolutely not and you've got to be
willing to be vulnerable and open and
honest
crazy vulnerable and that's it like i
want to be here maybe that's you two
taking a vacation to a place maybe
that's you looking at some real estate
y'all going to visit
um this is a longer term conversation
but i'll tell you this your martyrdos
your martyrdom i guess is the way to say
that
you just saying well i'm just going to
be here turns into frustration and that
frustration turns into anger that anger
turns into resentment and
everybody loses yep okay i would also
say beyond the family ties i would
sit down with your wife and show her
you're willing to listen to her fears
there are some other fears associated
with change absolutely
you believe in your family i got to see
all kids you got to honor that so don't
just all be about your vision i
i wanted to i didn't add the second part
but you better find out what she's
afraid of and to that end
answer the fears right but even then if
you got the answer before she has it you
better be patient my man but you live in
a
snapshot of history yep that you can
move where you want to live
in the united states yep so if you want
to move somewhere move something
uh hang on the line let's get you all
some tickets to money and marriage this
friday that
might help things get started kelly will
do
that that's going to be a great event
you better show up all right hey i want
to thank john deloney my colleague
always fun pal i want to thank our
producer james childs and kelly daniel
but you
america is who we think the most it's
your show this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
i'm ken coleman ramsey personality and
i'm joined by my colleague dr john
delaney who's a ramsey personality as
well we're here for you this
hour of course it's the show you have
come
to know and trust if you're new to the
show welcome aboard
uh we're talking about life and
specifically we talk about
money and then we talk i specifically on
my show talking about
purpose in your work not just a j-o-b
but doing something that you love that
matters deeply to you you can make the
income
that you need and the impact you want
you really can't that dream job is there
and so we'll help you with that that's
going to help you with that big shovel
then dr john delaney of course helping
people so much
on the dr john dolone show in the area
of relationships in life that's
emotional
and mental crises
with family members even in the
workplace if you're in a sticky nasty
situation and feel helpless
uh john it's got some great great
guidance and tools to help you as well
so we combine all of that
and we're here to help you so we are
again talking about life giving you hope
giving you a clear path
forward triple eight eight two five five
two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
john i um i was sharing earlier today on
my show
about the question that i think is the
most underrated question in the world
i think the question we have so much
fear
and anxiety around asking this question
and i'll share it with you and it's will
you help me
now in the context of my show which is
where we're talking about
moving into the space you want to move
into professionally that
that work you love and and then you're
in the space but now you want to move up
the ladder so that's the context
and i find that so many callers that
call in and they get so hung up in an
area when i go
you know you just you can ask for help
people
want to help us but i have learned of
course you know so much about this
from the psychology side in your studies
there is tremendous fear of rejection
john is what i hear
around this idea of saying will you help
me now i'm not saying you walk up to
people and say
will you help me right we don't say it
that way and i talked about four ways to
kind of
handle your posture there but i find
that that people are so willing to help
if we're humble and we kind of say hey i
need help i can't do this on my own
boy that's attractive that's the
greatest question
and then you're then and then beyond
humble uh you got to be specific
one of the things that i found early on
john i was kind of beating around the
bush
asking for certain people to help me get
into broadcasting here's what i've
learned about this
before people will tell you they want to
help you they kind of got to know if
they can help you
so be specific be specific and then
third be open
nothing makes me any more irritated
somebody will pull me aside say hey
can't can i get advice on something
will you help me i tell them and they go
that's kind of i wasn't thinking that
and they're not open-minded now that's
their prerogative right yeah but be
open-minded
because what you think is help what
you're expecting them and wanting them
to say may not be the help they offer
but it could be just as helpful
i hadn't thought of that is there
anything worse today someone asks you
for help and they're not asking for help
they're asking for you to affirm the
position they already have that's
exactly what's so annoying that's
exactly what's or
returned to them right you tell me i'm
right or they're terrified of the advice
you give them the help you give them
right and so they're not open to doing
that because that's well that's a little
bit too hard
wait a second that's gonna cause
sacrifice dave wait a second wait
wait wait you mean i gotta do rice and
beans beans and rice i gotta live like
no one else
i don't know or in my world you mean i
gotta tell my wife i'm sorry
yes because you're an idiot you did that
you said that
so she said it too well how about this
how about how about
a you decide i'm gonna be married
instead of being right yep and how about
you just take the high road yeah
or in this case the low road how about
you just say yeah go say i'm sorry yeah
go say hey let's
let's go talk about this yes yeah um i
think why are we so afraid to ask that
question will you help we have
wrapped our identity into this
tiny little package that we put we build
a wall around ourselves to protect
ourselves from
this idea that i'm not enough and we
think we have to have every answer to
every question
to do everything right and if somebody
comes and says hey uh here's a different
way to do something
it it's not a celebration it's a
challenge to who we are
it's a challenge to our identity you
know what i love
i it's one of my favorite things i love
being wrong
you know why not because i don't like
being told i'm stupid not being told
that i hurt somebody because i gave them
wrong advice
i love learning a new better way to do a
thing
and the other day my son and a couple of
his buddies were going fishing in the
creek and they said hey dad we're gonna
borrow your
lures i said you guys aren't gonna catch
anything in a two-foot water creek with
those lures
those are for and my son said can we try
and i said
you're gonna i don't want you to lose my
stuff and you're not gonna catch
anything
i got a text message on my wife's phone
from her
she said hank wants you to know that uh
you were wrong
they caught a fish i cheered
i was so happy the first thing i told
him was i'm so happy i was wrong
because you all caught you know what i'm
saying yeah i get it what a ridiculous
thing to tie yourself to
yeah like i got to be right yeah you
could be wrong yeah and there's just so
much pride too in this you know it's not
just
rejection i don't want anybody to think
that i can't do this
and the reality is is i don't care what
the profession is
i don't care if it's i'm trying to get
out of debt and i need some help from
you know my fpu coordinator or i don't
want to call a counselor i don't want to
sit down with my wife in front of a
counselor
the idea of asking for help is so
difficult for people
and i find it to be so paralyzing
because nobody gets
anywhere in any facet any area of life
without help you know dave loves to tell
the story of if you ever walk by a fence
pose to see a turtle see a turtle on the
top of the fence post you know one thing
he didn't get there by himself
he has a rolodex of people he asks their
advice on stuff oh on
home stuff and buying stuff and whatever
automobiles but
yeah every uh successful person i know
i remember the last dance the michael
jordan documentary oh
if you watch it there's something going
on in the background which is
the the most famous successful athlete
on earth especially at the time
was surrounded by a nutritionist
a personal trainer yeah uh head coach
assistant coaches weight room coach i
mean
don't forget teammates teammates
surrounded by experts who helped him
yeah get better yeah and then i've got a
dad who's sitting there
who's working his nine to five working
his butt off getting home
yeah i don't need to ask nobody i just
tell her was she oh oh man
i got people that are in miserable jobs
working in a situation that's sucking
the soul out of them they're living for
the weekend yeah they're fighting either
addiction
affairs alcoholism anything just to make
it to friday night
all because they won't say i need help
will you help me and you say hey i got a
flashlight into your situation
no i'm good yeah i'm good and we've got
to get over this we got to get over this
yeah because here's the deal people want
to help
and you know what's actually what's fun
is when you go to somebody you go hey
i need some knowledge or wisdom let me
break that down for a second knowledge
is i need some facts
wisdom is i need your perspective on a
situation
so i've got an a or b i got a fork in
the road or hey i want to get into
uh programming go sit down with a great
successful programmer
how'd you get into it watch those people
light up when you say i
i want to be like you yeah would you
give me some knowledge and wisdom on how
to get there because i don't know and i
man if it's not too much trouble i'll
buy your coffee i'll come with a pencil
i'll be specific
and i'll be forever grateful watch them
open up
and just do so much for you beyond what
you asked right
not all the time but many times john
there's few
fewer questions more warm to the human
heart than
hey can you help me yeah so john and i
are here to help you
some of you need to call i think
somebody right now is going i want to
call but i'm afraid to don't be
call us we'll help you this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show where we talk to
you about your life your
money your relationships your work
we're helping you live on purpose there
is a clear path
to be who you want to be and do
what you want to do triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five let's go to san
antonio texas where mike
joins us mike how can we help
i have a question i got a good job
opportunity but i'm just trying to make
sure that it's a good move
and i was going to try to see if you
guys could give me some advice on oh
absolutely tell us about the opportunity
so i'm currently in a job where i
basically do
tax planning but i want to move over and
do more of investments
and so this opportunity would give me
more to be an investment advisor
is that what you want to do it is what i
want to do
and it's basically right now
the only thing i would be giving up is
getting credentials and i would probably
be working a little bit more moving to
the other job
but if this job the only way to move up
is to get credentials
and i don't really know if i want to do
that but this job pays
maybe 20 grand more a year so i think it
would be a good move
yeah so you've already answered your own
question so uh this is what you want to
do
you're gonna make a lot more money and
you're gonna make more money uh
you don't want the credentials that uh
that you would supposedly have to get if
you stay where you are so i what
what are you concerned about all i've
heard is good is there well
the one concern that i have is that it's
more of a startup company
and so i just don't know about the
longevity of
maybe where i'm going as opposed to
where i'm at is very well established
i get it let me address that because i
hear that a lot uh mike how old a guy
are you
um i'm i'm 27. oh you're 27 this
probably won't work john but we'll go
with it because i'm committed
you ever heard of a company called enron
i have yeah you know the story about
enron
i sure do was enron a startup company
mike
well it was at one point yeah but the
point is it was a behemoth
it was almost too big to fall and it
fell
so fast it evaporated
it is into a mist it was that quick it
just wasn't there anymore
the point i'm making my colleague knows
where i'm going here
um your stable current position
isn't as stable as you think it is i
once interviewed the great jim collins
who wrote good to great
and i was interviewing him he in the
interview he said to me he said yeah i
get a lot of questions when i teach
business classes business school he's
got a young man coming to one time and
said
jim should i uh start my own company
which i've always wanted to do this is
before he this is right before he leaves
college
he said or should i go take the offer
for this big time company
that's got the stock options and
everything because that's the sure thing
and collins who is a contrarian a
beautiful nice contrarian but a
contrarian said to the young man
what i'm saying to you mike and he said
yeah that big sure thing is not a big
sure thing they're one crisis
one ethical one wall street slip up
they're
one moment away from that sure thing
you being one of the first people to get
laid off because you're the young guy
and you're new
he said go chase the thing that you want
to do
he said paint on your own canvas and he
said
ken most people love the paint by
numbers art right
green on number two if you grew up in
our era paint red on number
one and so forth and so on versus
painting their own canvas and i think
mike what you've been offered is an
opportunity
to paint the painting on your canvas am
i
laying it down for you to where you
understand what i'm saying mike
for sure i think that's great advice um
don't look
is there anything that i need to be
looking for when i take it i mean
any advice from starting a new job on a
startup that you can think of or just
sure and go forward well a couple things
so the only thing i want you to check
before you say yes is i would like you
to look into the culture
i can't tell you how many times john
i've had callers on the ken coleman show
say ken i took what i thought was the
dream job
and it's it's six weeks later and i'm
miserable because he didn't check the
culture gotcha so
mike this feels like this is a
no-brainer from the work the position
itself the type of work you want to do
certainly a no-brainer as a financial
opportunity with which
looks like there's a ladder attached to
it as well so it's check check
check i think the last check box before
i say yes is
do your homework and find out what the
culture is like over there
do they develop and promote their people
is one of the things i'm looking for
how do they treat their vendors their
customers do some homework on that make
sure there's no red flags
and then once we get that i think yeah
you go for it i don't think this is a
big rick now as far as how to win
uh i'm going to give this advice to you
when in a new role
there's three things you do first thing
is
when you take the job go deeper than
just the job interview
and make sure that there is a very clear
understanding between you and your
leader on what your role is
what's a win look like for me not just
the job description
what does a win look like and how am i
measured against that
that's know your role that's clarity the
second thing is accept your role
see you're super fired up right now mike
because this is a jump for you
professionally and financially but
that's going to wear off at some point
and i don't want you to forget that
you were really excited about this at
one point so you got to accept your role
this is my role now i got to win in the
now where there is no next step up the
ladder that's
attitude the final thing is go way
beyond the role
maximize the role give way beyond
what the job description is and what the
measurables are look to help employ uh
teammates look to go deeper to lead and
help your boss
really dive deep know your role accept
your role maximize your role those three
things if you do that you're gonna start
really hot out of the gate and you make
yourself very promotable
i wonder what it is ken that makes
everyone's got different stories that
they tell himself
everyone's got different stories people
told them when they were growing up but
i wonder what
story is told to a guy like mike
who's smart driven
then he looks in the mirror and says
yeah but i can't trust you
he knew the answer right he knew where
we were headed with this thing
yeah but something way down there said
you know what you're probably not that
smart you're probably not
you probably don't know you know what i
mean and i do that
yeah i'm sure you yeah we all do i think
that's interesting
that's a very interesting angle uh
because i
i hear it with him he's going i hear
startup
and there's something about our culture
and actually i'm going to throw this
back to you
because i i also heard him basically
saying well
i'm at a i'm at a company that's been
around whatever many years means
credibility to him
and the startup a two-year-old company
all of a sudden
may not be wise the question is is he
getting that from somebody else yeah
somebody told him what you like what is
it about us that we doubt that something
can be
stable just because it's new no i i is
it that
i think i think we would rather be
miserable and quote unquote certain
oh i didn't know that live our dream or
go get them
miserable over uncomfortable yeah that's
it and
uncomfortable uncomfortable man that's a
rant in itself
go for it we've solved for discomfort
we've pathologized discomfort
you know what keep going you deserve to
never be
too cool or too warm forget weather
we can have a 72 degree home to a 72
degree card or 72 degree office and back
and back and
by the way your shoes should always be
really comfortable well don't exercise
we'll just give you some
some of this or some of that we've just
solved for discomfort
and we're finding out is discomfort is
where you grow
yes our bodies are desperate for it our
relationships are just for it our
desperate our mental health is desperate
for it
that's when you find out who you are
that you find out purpose that's when
you find out passion that's when you
find an accomplishment
we tried for 20 or 30 years just to look
at kids and say you know what y'all are
special
we're just gonna give you self-esteem by
telling it to you all the time come on
and they went
bananas hey we don't want anybody to
feel bad about losing three to one in
the soccer game so we're not gonna keep
score and oh by the way
everybody at the end of the year gets a
trophy because we don't want to make
bobby and susie uncomfortable and you
know who knows
that we're lying to him the kids the
kids of course they do
they come off after losing a game 17-1
and we throw confetti on them
by the way everybody keeps score yes i
need to confess something right here on
the ramsay show
this is a very this is a very healing
moment to my colleague this is ken's
confession
so i was coaching uh james i gotta taste
i was coaching
a fifth a five and six-year-old soccer
team my freshman year of college
and we're having the coaches meeting and
the director for the ymca says we will
not keep score in this league so please
if your kids bring it up distract them
don't keep score
first game we're down three another at
halftime i pulled them all together gave
them their orange slice and says hey
guys
we're down 3-0 you gave him a gift ken
i think so at least i believe so i
couldn't do it john i felt like a
sellout
everybody keeps score go do the thing
that you want to do even if it's
uncomfortable today
go this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show welcome back
america thrilled to have you with us
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that is
the number to jump in john deloney is my
co-host this hour i'm ken coleman we're
both ramsey
personalities we host shows on the
ramsey network he hosts
the john doctor john delaney show and i
host the ken coleman show
and we'd love for you to check those out
as well and uh
john is helping you in life and
relationships mental
emotional wellness just some serious
stuff going on over there really
gripping gripping conversations
and you can get help and you can get
help here as well
and then on the ken coleman show we're
helping you get where you want to go
discover what you were born to do we're
talking about purpose in your work
you were created to fill a unique role
you are needed and you must do it so
a little bit about us and of course we
are
standard co-hosts here on the ramsey
show when answering your questions about
money as well so we're talking about
life and it is your conversation
before we get back to the phones uh john
you and i
recently got homes but uh the real
estate season is
really gonna fire back up even though
it's really white hot it's just around
the corner
with uh the summer starting to come to
an end unbelievable
and this year things are really
different home prices higher
competition between buyers is intense
and sellers
new you need to know what you're doing
if you're going to make the most out of
the sale of your home
so if you're thinking about buying or
selling a home this year
here's a piece of simple advice that
could save you a six figure mistake
don't jump into something you don't
understand
if you don't know where to start or
you're not sure if you're ready
for a mortgage if you have questions
about how to buy or sell a home
get advice from a professional who's
done this before we'd love you to
connect with one of our endorsed
local provider agents these are real
estate agents that we trust here at
ramsey solutions
our elps will help you guide excuse me
will help guide you
through the entire home buying or home
selling process
they're going to teach you every step of
the way so that you feel clear and
confident go to ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash agent to connect with one of our
trusted elp
agents triple eight eight two five five
two five is the number let's go to
columbia south carolina
jeremy joins us there jeremy how can we
help
hey david uh sorry ken and dr john how
are y'all we are living the dream what's
up
uh got a question my wife and i are in
baby step two again i've called to talk
to you before on your show
uh like i said we're in baby step two uh
trucking pretty good we're about 12 to
18 months out from being completely
debt-free
minus a house obviously but my wife has
decided she wants to try and get a new
car
which would be a major upgrade and
vehicle
um obviously that's not in the
ramsey plan and without you know coming
across as a jerk and you know trying to
be respectful of her
what kind of how do we navigate this
without saying i'm right you're wrong
you're right i'm wrong
you know not trying to be biased but
just say what what's better for our
future y'all have any advice on that
i i would say first and foremost this
isn't dave's plan
this is jeremy's plan this is the plan
to change germany's house dave laid the
steps out
as long as this is an external thing
being forced on your family
by some mostly bald old man
on the radio right and i'd say that if
he was sitting here
uh i don't know yeah i would would you
um
then there's gonna be a
your wife is going to feel imposed upon
because this isn't a joint vision
right um this is okay i'll go along with
this guy's thing and whatever and if it
keeps my husband
hey but i want to get a new car right so
for some reason she's not fully bought
in yet
y'all aren't on the same page with this
deal were y'all
at one time on the same page why are we
coming up with a new car here
yeah we were um we actually
downgraded both vehicles
to be able to afford them and now we're
kind of
seems like we're just making another 180
and all this has happened with them like
six months ago so it's kind of like what
i'm not even sure what's brought this
home but
you know it's not a you're crazy type
thing
it's just you know
so what up here how do we go about it so
jeremy if i'm hearing you correctly
she bought in she's like okay let's do
this baby step thing and she was in
on downgrading uh your car so that you
could pay off debt and move along am i
hearing that correctly
correct so she was on board now all of a
sudden
uh she's not ranting and raving saying
you've lost your mind i don't want to do
this she's just going
i've changed my mind again i want a nice
car is that what i'm hearing
pretty much yeah um the fact that you
say again i'm gonna throw this back to
john
from the professional counseling side
but uh just as the observer in the
conversation on this one
the fact that you just said i'm not sure
what's changed
there's part of our problem we need to
find out what
is really going on the fact that you
called us and you're not quite sure what
has changed means i think you need to
dig in a little bit more about where she
is and and what has caused this and i'm
calling bull crap on that too jeremy
what has changed
you know oh well
one thing she starts a new job tomorrow
i'm not i'm sorry
she goes to figure out her new salary
and everything tomorrow the job change
will actually be next weekend okay and
next month
and that'll be she'll be working at the
same school our two girls are gonna go
to
okay um is she expecting a raise
that's kind of what i'm waiting to see
we'll
hopefully we'll find that out tomorrow
and we just don't know concrete numbers
yet i think she is
is she feeling self-conscious about
pulling up to her new job or her new
promotion with an old car
it may be so here's here's the thing i i
think there's some stuff here the car
here is the symptom
for some reason shape form for some
reason
you all to have separated this this
mission here what you're on together the
path together and hey by the way this
happens to every married couple on earth
about a million different things it can
happen on the way to a restaurant
hey you want to have mexican food
tonight sure that sounds great we're
headed out that way and then halfway
there it's like oh oh we're just gonna
go there
like i thought we were i thought we had
decided that it happens all the time
yeah
so nothing's wrong with your marriage
nothing's wrong your relationship but
y'all have gotten off track
and this is a time for you to flip the
lights on and turn the music off
and take her out somewhere and say hey
we all sit down
we all agreed to this we are all in
we're going to change our family tree
we're going to change the trajectory of
our our life our kids life
we're all bought in we even sold our
cars and got these two
not great cars and then you just came
and
laid this on me i you know you know i
want to provide you the best i want to
be a great provider
you've got an awesome job you're about
to get a raise it's going to accelerate
this plan
but now you say you want to get into
tell me what tell me what happened
because we were on the same page here
and bring it back to the mission bring
it back to the goal
bring it back to hey we're in this thing
together
and for god's sake this is not you guys
are the heroes of this journey
right dave wrote the plan financial
peace university we got these seven
steps
but you've got to make it y'all's vision
for your life
not dave ramsey's right sit down with
her take her and get back together on
the same page and you all create a
picture of what it's going to look like
and something you can go back to and go
back to
i hope you get a she gets a massive
raise and it just accelerates this whole
thing and she'll get you go get
emergency fund and she'll get that new
car sooner rather than later yeah i
i would agree completely with john
jeremy i would just add when you're
having this conversation let's put some
real dates on there like you told us i
forget what you said at the beginning of
the call
but there is a payoff date if we stay
disciplined okay
so if you sit down with her and you do
all the things that john said and go hey
babe listen
with this new raise we may shave three
months six months off
and at this point then we're gonna go
this many more months we got the
emergency fund in place
the three to six months and now we can
begin to cash flow
the car and i can i'm gonna get you this
hey put a picture of it on the fridge
yeah like combine her vision
to the mission people will suffer john
they'll suffer and sacrifice
if they know where they're headed
but the ambiguity the ambiguity in
marriage is just as bad as ambiguity in
the professional setting when a leader
goes
come on everybody work those extra hours
i heard so much of this during coven ken
they just we worked hard because of it
well the leaders never said hey it's for
three or four months yeah
just give me three and then we're gonna
get over it you gotta get clear the
ambiguity is
crushing people in the debt-free oh man
i have a goal do it together
it's awesome thanks for the call jeremy
don't move more ramsey show coming up
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm kid coleman
joined by my colleague
dr john delony and we are taking your
calls triple eight
eight two five five two two
five our scripture of the day comes from
proverbs
21 20 precious treasure and oil are in a
wise man's dwelling but a foolish man
devours it our quote from the legendary
self-help guru jim rohn
formal education will make you a living
self-education will make
you a fortune amen to that i absolutely
agree with that
all right let's get back to the phones
uh amber is up in fort worth
texas amber how can we help
uh yes hi my husband and i we opened a
business
uh we owned a bakery back in 2019 in
december
so we ran our bakery all through the
pandemic and everything
um we felt like we were actually
doing pretty well considering people
were not leaving our house
and we were going to farmers markets
um and so people were at least going to
go and buy brand new and
produce and stuff from the markets and
even learning from us online
but now that the stores are back open
again and people are getting back to
their regular lives
we've noticed a decrease in our sales um
we're really struggling
uh now financially uh just overall in
general with the
rise of cost and everything and just
wondering what we can do
to get our bakery up off the ground and
to be where it needs to be
okay so i want to know a little bit more
just a quick snapshot
in 2019 you started it and it was doing
pretty hot
during the coronavirus is that what i
heard yes
okay so how much has it dipped and i'm
trying to get a ballpark you can give me
percentages or you can give me real
numbers per month i mean when you say
get it off the ground how bad is it
right now give me a
at its highest point and maybe in 2020
and where
where you are now give me a snapshot
well in 2020 we were having
people ordering regularly from us online
we have
online sales and orders and deliveries
um and
as well as the farmer's market which has
always been consistent
we always sell out on our farmers market
that's always been consistent we make
about 500 a weekend
but the what we need to see the monday
through friday
the regular everyday um that has dropped
how much down significantly almost 100
it's like people decided now that they
can get out and they can go slower again
and all these things but they don't need
us
okay so your online orders went from
give me i need a number and the reason
i'm driving at this i'm going to try to
give you
all right uh yeah it was for example
back in this last december during the
christmas and time and stuff
we were having you know 15 orders a week
um and we sell soda breads and muffins
and various things and so that you know
that adds up okay so average the
delivery
how much how much how much revenue were
you were you bringing in
on a week or a month at your high point
how much revenue
uh at our height we were taking in you
know about
i would say 750.
how much 150 750 a week okay
so this is a side hustle for you guys
correct
well no so when you originally my
husband worked in pizza
he worked up to being a manager and then
found out he was getting paid to make
1200 salary so you're but you're making
750 dollars a week i mean
right that's that's about three grand a
month you guys have been living off of
that and now all of a sudden it's just
dropped to this floor and the only money
you're making is 500 bucks on a weekend
at the farmer's market right and that's
really so much and we're
wondering what we can do okay all right
so listen
to the bakery what we want it to be we
got bigger problems in the bakery
okay i'm going to get back to the bakery
okay i'm sorry i was having a hard time
understanding him so i'm sorry to ask
all the follow-ups
okay first things first uh this bakery
is
is a labor of love you guys are really
excited about this and and if we can
make this go this is the dream am i
understanding that
yes okay great okay great
i love it but here's the deal we've got
to shift our mindset right now
this is no longer the full-time play
something has shifted and it was corona
people were doing everything online now
all of a sudden they can get out they're
buying their
we got to figure that out i can't solve
that for you on this call but i'm going
to tell you this
a don't give up the dream b we need to
shift this bakery
to what it really is it is a side hustle
we cannot live off of the situation
right now
and if you guys don't realize this and
act on this you're going to be in a
world of hurt
so you hubs i'm going to recommend some
tough love both of you go get day jobs
and then we can still do the farmer's
market on the weekend best i can tell
and then we gotta find a way to get back
on that online business now we're gonna
have to adjust because people have
adjusted
but i think with a little bit of
innovation talking to your customers
those people who bought from you
don't harass them say hey we'd like to
do a survey
and and find out uh what it would take
for them to come back i would look at
the delivery model you guys are gonna
have to dive into that
but you can do that better when it's not
the pressure
to live off of this business i i think
entrepreneurs put themselves in such
danger john
when something like this shifts and they
go oh
we can't we got to hang on yes hang on
but not full time well and i'm not
full-time i'm thinking of
man you have this picture that we run a
bakery and we are a farmer's market
bakery
yeah we like those kind of you know what
you may do you may have to get in a van
and go be a construction site bakery
that's exactly right or
a uh high school parking lot bakery or
we're going to go to some of the local
community colleges there
in fort worth and we're going to have
i've seen some remarkable
would they go from 11 p.m to 3 a.m
deliveries of
baker baked goods to college students
right whatever it is
you're going to have to shake up the
picture and say we got
super creative beginning of corona and
created an online presence
well now that's gone and this is the
fun slash nightmare slash excitement of
being a small business owner is
basically every month you're reinventing
your business right until
you get to a certain level right and so
amber the last thing i want to say on
this and i don't want you to be
discouraged
i want you to hear me say i don't want
you to let go of this stream but this
has got to be a part-time dream here's
why
as you reported the story to us the
emotion that you had
around the height of your business was
so high but in all reality
those numbers aren't that big it's a low
margin business
and so you guys are going to have to
figure this out do not quit
keep it part time farmers market like
john said
reinvent ourselves test some new things
you proved that you could sell
baked goods to people people want to eat
your food they want to eat your food you
proved it but
you're gonna have to reinvent and you're
gonna have to scale but i want to
caution you you guys weren't doing as
well as
you think you were and this is a tough
business so you better be in it for the
long haul
that's the mind shift and so when we
shift our mind now we're going to go
okay what does that mean
this is a long-haul play for us we're
not going to get discouraged but i'm
going to tell you right now
if you both don't get day jobs soon
you're going to put
unnecessary pressure on this business
and this dream
and it'll be hard to withstand that well
and that pressure ends up
in your marriage that's right there's
all kinds of ripple effects
so here here's the theory oh yeah there
you go so here's the three steps yeah
the stress of
lack of money this last six months since
things have really started going down
has been
very stressful that's exactly right and
that's what that's like
kids call people to ups at night yep um
we'll see so you're already there you're
already there right you're ready you
guys are taking steps yes
i want y'all to go out and here's the
three things you have to do
an acknowledgement session and this is
vulnerable this is hard this is
embarrassing this is shameful it's all
those things
but you've got to sit down with them
with a yellow pad and a calculator
and a diner together and say this is the
state of this business
and then you have to grieve and we
always think grieving is you know the
end of time somebody passed away
and there is that but all grief is it's
the gap between what we hoped for
and what is right we hoped that granddad
would live forever
we hope this business would go and it's
not and we just have to sit there and
slump our shoulders sometimes we have to
cry sometimes we have to journal
whatever it is and you just have to just
to go
and then you got to own what's next do
we really want to keep doing this are we
ruling to drive to construction sites at
5am and at lunchtime
and go to college campuses are we
willing to do this but you got to own
what's next but you got to acknowledge
it
grieve it and then say we're all in on
what comes next
and you all get to do that to guess the
beauty of it otherwise you're going to
lose your marriage over this thing too
that's why we call here at ramsay
solutions work that you love
passion is the root word of it in the
latin means to suffer
are you willing to suffer not just
emotional and financial but just
patience
you guys are so you're heading the right
direction thank you for the call hey i
want to thank my
colleague dr john delay thanks pal
always fun hanging with you
i want to thank our producer james
childs our associate producer kelly
daniel and
you america thank you this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you